- Today in this video
I'm going to teach you
a communication technique
which is extremely powerful,
which I personally use
almost every single day.
You can use it for oral communication,
for written communication,
for all different types of contexts,
such as internal team
communication, client communication.
Or also for instance in job interviews.
It is a technique that
I've seen extensively used
in consulting but not so
much in other industries
or by other people
working not in consulting.
So trust that this video
once again can help
in lifting the veil
and hopefully making these
techniques available to everyone
else out there as well
independent from where you work.
So welcome back to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm a former McKinsey
consultant and on Firm Learning
I want to help you to become
successful in the first years
of your career.
So if you like this,
please like this video,
and also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
And now without further
ado, let's dive into it.
And I will use a little
exercise to illustrate my point.
And this is a type of exercise
that was quite commonly used
in onboarding programs like
McKinsey, BCG, or Bain,
because these are the situations
that you will often face.
And I will draw from an
exercise that I already used
to illustrate a point
in one of my past videos
on top-down communication.
If you've not seen it yet,
I can also very much recommend
to you to check it out.
I will link the video somewhere above here
so that you can click on it
after you've watched this video.
So I will now read the
scenario here from my screen.
The situation is that you
are part of a project team
that is looking into
market entry opportunities
for a new project line.
You conducted lots of
interviews with internal
and external experts on the topic.
You looked into data from
the finance department,
from the marketing team,
and you have a first result
that France likely would be
a great fit for that product.
And indeed this is because you
conducted consumer research
and French consumers
will likely appreciate
the offering most.
You looked into the competition
and currently there are
no strong competitors
yet involved in France.
And you also looked into distribution
and warehousing capabilities,
but your company at the moment
would be very well set up
to serve the French market.
So, so far so good,
same scenarios in the last exercise.
But my point that I want to
drag out here is a different one
because now the CEO walks
in and she asks you,
hey, what is going on?
What's the status with the project?
Can you just summarize what
your preliminary results
on that are?
So how would you answer this
and this time now I do not want
you to think about the top
down communication concepts,
because we've covered these
already in this other video,
but I want to focus on a very
specific different point.
So if you want feel free
to pause the video now
and think for an answer for yourself,
how would you reply to such a question?
But now let's into a sample answer,
what could you have
said in this situation?
And here, let me just read this out.
Our current hypothesis is that
France will be the best fit
for our product line.
We looked into consumer research
and the French consumers
will like you appreciate
our offering most.
The competitive landscape is
also important to consider.
In France it would be the
first with this offering.
What's also great is that we
already have solid logistics
and distribution capabilities in France.
So again feel free to pause this video
and think about this answer.
Is this a good answer,
is this a solid answer?
So what's the case for sure is
that this answer does comply
with top-down communication.
This important principle
that we introduced
in the other video.
Though is this really the strongest answer
that you could give?
And my main point of criticism
would be that this answer
feels a bit random.
It's a more or less random list of points.
It lacks structure.
It feels like a cloth line,
like the result of a
brainstorming where the person
was just thinking about
reasons why the French market
would be the best to end
up for the product line.
And maybe these are indeed
all the relevant reasons
why the French market would be the best,
but maybe the person
also forgot to mention
one or two other important reasons.
Who knows, right?
So this is at least not an
answer that would give the
recipient a lot of confidence
that this person had
it really all laid out,
really clearly organized,
and really knew exactly
what the most relevant
reasons would be.
So let's contrast that
with the second example
of what you could have had answered.
So our current hypothesis is that France
will be the best fit for our product line.
This is based on three reasons.
First consumer research
shows that French consumers
will appreciate our offering.
Second, the competitive
landscape in France
is not yet developed.
We will be the first with this offering.
And third our logistics and
distribution capabilities
are already set up to
serve the French market.
What do you think about
this answer option?
Is this a better way of answering this?
I would argue, yes this is the case
because this is answer not only follows
top down communication but
this answer also follows
the so-called rule of three.
You are clearly starting
your answer by saying
that there are three reasons
for that, three points,
three main arguments, and
then you are mentioning them.
First, second, third.
And I hope you agree that this
feels much more structured,
much more well organized than
just to randomly starting
to talk about a first point
and then later maybe a second
point and then another one
and another one.
And it all feels like brainstorming.
When you compare the
answers next to each other,
they seem very similar.
What has been said is
very very similar indeed.
But trust me that the
choice in example number two
would be perceived as
much more structured,
much more well organized.
And this is true up to the
point that in consulting
this was so frequently
used that it was considered
almost a meme.
Whenever a client or partner
would be asking you a question,
you would likely always say
something like, yes, for sure.
So let me mention three points on that,
or yes, for sure, let me
mention three arguments
where this is the case.
Or this is my recommendation,
and this is for three reasons.
You will almost always try
to find a way to structure
your answers in the way
that you could start them
with introducing three distinct points.
And yet the truth is in most
of the cases you did not really
have three points like
that ready in your head
when you just started
beginning giving this answer.
You would in most cases just
start with the first reason
and the likeliest second reason
is what you would be able to
easily come up with as well.
And then just on the way you
would try to come up with
a third poin, a third reason.
And my experience is if you practice this
and do this regularly,
you will almost always be able to mention
a point number three,
even though maybe this third
point is not the most relevant,
the most important one
that you could have said.
But I do know that the biggest
fear that people have when
answering questions like this
is that they cannot come up
with a third point on the way.
So let me share two things
that you can almost always say
are the third point if we
really cannot come up with
anything else that is more
content related on the way.
And the first suggestion is
to talk about next steps.
So what you can almost
always say as a third point
is what will you do next?
What are the next things you will look at?
When is the next meeting
where you need to have
this all ready?
Talking about next steps is so easy
because there's almost always a next step.
You're almost never completely finished
with a piece of work on an analysis.
So definitely something
that should be able to
help you out here.
And my second suggestion
will be to talk about risks
or downsides or doubts
that you still have.
So maybe you looked into
something you are coming
to a conclusion and you're
talking about point one
and point two of that conclusion,
but then in most cases there
will be something where maybe
you will need to look into further.
You're not a hundred percent sure about
or see a certain risk and
dependency where your progress is
dependent on the work of another person,
maybe another colleague or another client.
So these are things that you
should always be able to say
as a point number three if
we really cannot come up with
anything else that would make sense.
This rule of three is
really extremely powerful
and very very often used in consulting.
By the way not only by
associates or project leads,
so maybe the more junior consultants,
but especially also by the partners.
You will see partners and
senior partners use this rule of
three all the time, more
in team communication,
but also in communication to the clients.
So trust that this alone
should be something
that should make you think whether this is
maybe worth at least trying for you
for your work routines this way.
But of course I would also be interested
in your experiences.
What do you think about the rule of three?
Did you already use it in the past?
Where does it work or maybe
doesn't it work that way?
Let us know in the comments.
I trust this will be helpful
for every single person
in the Firm Learning community.
So if you took any
value out of this video,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications
to stay up to date on all my content.
Big, big thanks to all the
members of Firm Learning.
You're really helping me
out here on the channel.
Thanks for that.
And feel free to also follow
me on LinkedIn, Instagram,
Tik Tok or Twitch.
You'll find links to my socials below
in the video description.
I release videos every single Saturday.
So see you again next week.
Until then bye-bye all the best to you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.